In the previous lecture, we have discussed
that machine learning algorithms can be broadly
divided into 3 categories: supervised learning,
unsupervised learning, and reinforcement learning.
In supervised learning we give the computer a
data set with what is called a target variable.
That's whether or not the person had heart
disease, or did not have heart disease.
We then give a series of input variables. The
modeling algorithms automatically generates
the model, which establishes a relationship
between the target and the input variables.
In other words, you give the inputs,
and along with the input, you give the
outcome.
Unsupervised learning is a search for
homogeneous subsets that produces one or more
possible segmentations of the data that differ
by how similar the cases are within the segment
and how many subsets there are, and how common
or rare they are. The whole idea of homogeneous
is just put similar cases together. Now,
the computer will help you do the search.
But, you have to decide how similar is
similar enough for your application.
You have to decide how many subsets you want there
to be. And you have to decide how rare or common
the subsets are going to be.
Unsupervised is actually more difficult for the
human analyst than supervised in many cases.
For instance, take a look. Let's just say we
were asking our computer to perform unsupervised
segmentation on these blocks. Should we
separate them so that they're blue and non-blue?
Or maybe red and non-red? Should we be
focusing on shape or is that less important?
Should we be focusing on size? It's probably
impossible to answer outside some context.
So, the computer will help group, but only in
partnership with a human analyst that knows what
the goal of the segmentation will be.
So sometimes, we do see definitions of
unsupervised learning that make it seem like
it's pretty much supervised, but when you can't
find a target variable or you don't have ready
access to a target variable. It's actually a very
different set of goals when we do unsupervised
learning.
The third area of machine learning
is called reinforcement learning.
Only recently has this been a source of confusion,
mostly because of two application areas that have
gotten a lot of excitement. Technologies like
driverless cars and technologies like the one
that was able to beat the world champion at go,
these operate in a very different way. At first,
they sound like supervised. But they're quite
different. What's happening here is you're not
presenting the algorithm with a very large number
of input and output pairs. Rather, it's working in
an environment and it's correct and incorrect not
for each row of data, but it's rather rewarded for
correct actions it takes in the environment. This
is the kind of technology that arises for very
cool things like watching a robot stumble
and then as it practices it gets better.
Next, let's try and understand
unsupervised machine learning.
Put simply, this is the process of
taking a lot of unstructured data,
running it through lots of compute, and
somehow getting structured data out of it.
Example, let's say that in a room there
are five people talking with each other.
That's a lot of unstructured data, but everybody's
voice is like a thumbprint. So just by having a
computer analyze it we could split that into
individual audio streams. Or, let's say we
have lots of documents, and we wish to be able
to categorize them. But, we don't know how many
categories, but we want to categorize them.
Or, you got lots of pictures, and you want
to find similarities between those pictures.
This is not just recognizing faces, so let's
say person X appears in these pictures. That's
a very common application, but it could also
be how many pictures are daytime or nighttime?
How many pictures have bright lights in them? How
many pictures have modern buildings versus nature?
These are various categories. So, these are
various examples of unsupervised machine learning.
At a high level you can think of unsupervised
learning as something that where data points have
no labels associated with them. So you don't know
what categories these will fall into. The goal is
to somehow organize the data to make sense of it.
The important point here is that unsupervised
machine learning can often be a precursor to
supervised machine learning.
Example that we have five people talking, and we
get individual audio streams out of them. Now that
you have split those audio streams, perhaps,
we can try, and find out what language they're
talking in? What is the sentiment? We can analyze
the text, try and gain meaning, or knowledge out
of what they were talking about. All of that
then gets into supervised machine learning.